well I was 16 when my brother died in a
car accident he was 19 and he'd been out
with all his friends drinking and having
fun he was out with his best friend and
at the end of the night after several
shots and several pints they waited for
a taxi but because it was a Wednesday
night no taxis came so they decided that
my brother would be fine to drive that
he wasn't too drunk and he drove home he
was driving at 80 miles per hour and he
was twice over the limit and he was
supposed to turn a corner and he just
drove straight into a tree and basically
I mean his friend was really lucky you
didn't didn't come up with any severe
injuries but my brother was in the car
um and the car set on fire so we we
couldn't see his body we couldn't get to
say goodbye to him properly I found out
four days before my first GCSE exam and
it was um the worst thing to ever happen
to me just because nothing stays the
same after something like that and one
decision made by someone else has had so
much effect on so many other people's
lives and he was there on Sunday and
gone by the thursday and
he was 19 he he made such a stupid
decision such a bad mistake and it you
know nothing nothing would change it now
he was never a particularly good
decision-maker but he was so full of
life and he has so much potential and so
being 20 now I'm older than he ever was
he'll ever be and knowing knowing I have
now and knowing that he um will never
have that because I just I just think
that people make such a brat decisions
because they think it would never happen
to them it could never happen to them
but we all thought on all of my family
all of tom's friends even you never
think it's going to happen to you um but
it did and we have to live with that so
i just think that for the sake of
people's families for the sake of
everyone they care about well the a
moment of madness really does lead to
what we all suffer which is definitely a
lifetime full of sadness for the loss of
my brother